in this video we will be ranking all
known titan shifters from weakest to
strongest we'll start with tom sava and
we will slowly start moving towards much
more powerful titans tom sava was an
eldian researcher and warrior who held
the power of the titans tom was the
former inheritor of the beast titan
before transferring this power to zeke
yeager in his early adulthood tom lived
as a resident of the liberio internment
zone at some point in his life he fell
in love with a marlin woman knowing that
it was forbidden for eldians and
marlians to marry he purposely hid his
alien armband whenever he saw her and
the two soon got married and had a son
several years later she discovered his
eldean heritage and promptly killed both
their son and herself in shame tom
discovered them shortly afterward and
was overcome with grief he would later
become a warrior and eventually proved
himself to inherit one of the nine
titans the beast titan his beast titan
form possessed features of a sheep
having had a pair of dark curved horns
on its head a lengthened muzzle and a
nose resembling the animal it takes
after he possessed all regular titan
abilities and didn't have any unique
power of his own it's presumed that tom
did not utilize his beast titan form
often due to claiming that his titan was
not useful in war so we have to put him
at the bottom of our list number 17 peak
finger it's well known throughout the
series that the kart titan is not the
most useful titan when it comes to
combat so our beloved peak is the next
titan shifter on our list pete grew up
in the liberial internment zone and
joined the warrior program as soon as
she was eligible so she could provide
medical care for her father after
performing well enough she was chosen to
inherit the car titan when she arrived
in shiganshina district at parity island
with zeke yeager she'd used her titan to
scout enemy positions and provide zeke
with boulders to throw at the soldiers
she doesn't engage in battle herself but
rather stays behind zeke and helps him
she usually keeps cargo and supplies on
her back and is labeled as a support
unit when zeke is defeated and almost
killed by levi pique comes to his rescue
and carries him towards town later on
she is present at the battle of fort
slava at the climax of the war between
marley and the mid-east allied forces
there we can see her titan modified for
battle being fully armored and equipped
for four machine guns operated by her
panzer unit while most other humans
containing the power of the titans are
unable to stay in their titan forms for
extended periods of time pique is
actually able to remain in this form for
extremely long periods of time due to
the incredible endurance of the car
titan during the marley mideast war
pique stated that she spent around two
months in her titan form and as a result
has begun to walk with the aid of a
crutch pique also claims she can perform
hundreds of consecutive transformations
number 16. marcel galliard marcel was an
albion boy who joined the warrior
program at a young age with his younger
brother porco marcel proved to be very
talented during his training notably in
tests of strength and endurance and
eventually he stood among the seven
remaining warrior candidates for
inheriting the power of the titans
marcel was worried for his younger
brother and never wanted him to inherit
the power of the titans in the first
place so he intentionally diminished
porco's reputation and made reiner the
leading candidate to inherent the
armored titan as the jaw titan's most
prominent feature marcel's titan form
possessed a great biting force which was
strong enough to crush cannons due to
its small size marcel's jaw titan had a
high level of speed and agility shortly
after inheriting the titan he was sent
to parody island with other warriors in
order to capture and retrieve the
founding titan on the first morning of
their arrival marcel was eaten by a pure
titan while trying to save reiner
because he died at a very young age we
can't accurately tell how powerful he
really was and for that reason we
couldn't rank him any higher on this
list number 15 frida reese imagine
having the most powerful titan in the
world but not knowing how to use it
that's the case of our next titan
shifter frida reese frida was the true
queen of the walls and the last of the
fountain titans before it got merged
with the attack titan it's believed that
around the time she turned 15 frida
learned that her uncle yuri reese was
dying and was the holder of their
family's titan she volunteered to be
yuri's successor and injected herself
with a titan serum transforming for the
first time in the cavern below the
chapel frida's pure titan consumed her
uncle's upper body and she received not
only the titan powers that yuri had
inherited but the memories of the world
before the walls frida essentially
became the living book of humanity and
had the power to spread the information
if she chose but like all the others
before her she was influenced by the
will of her ancestor carl fritz and
chose not to frida is present with the
reese family the knight grisha jaeger
raids the reese chapel she listens as
grecia pleads with the rhys family to
protect the people from the titan
invasion for a moment frida appears
willing to agree to greisha's request
but then she seems to be forced to
change her mind due to the first king's
will grisha had no other option but to
engage in battle with frida and he
successfully defeated and stole the
founding titan from her because of her
royal blood frida had the full abilities
of the founding titan but she was not
experienced in using it number 14.
grisha jaeger risha yeager was an eldian
doctor who originated from the liberio
internment zone in marley and was one of
the eldian restorationists and later the
father of erin yeager grisha joined ld
and restorationists after learning that
his younger sister fey was actually
murdered by marley officers through his
activities and a mole in the marley
legal system named the owl grisha got
information about elding history and met
dina fritz a person of royal descent a
year later they got married and had a
child which they named zeke during this
time marley and military started a
warrior program and grisha decided that
he would send his own son into the
program as a mole for them zeke's
performance in the warrior program was
very poor and it looked like there was
no chance for him to be selected at the
age of seven zeke exposed his parents
and all of the restorationists and they
were sentenced to go to parody island as
pure titans when grisha arrived at the
top of the wall the owl finally revealed
himself as one of the marley officers he
saved grecia and told him everything
about the power of the titans upon
getting the power of attack titans
greisha successfully infiltrated the
walls and married a woman named carla
who later gave birth to a son they named
aaron while living inside the walls he
eventually discovered the location of
the rhys family's chapel as well as the
hatch leading down to the basement where
the succession rituals take place grisha
revealed himself to be an eldian from
beyond the walls and begged frida reese
to use her founding titan ability to
save the district from the titans that
are breaking in however succumbing to
the will of carl fritz she refuses to
act he then transforms into his titan
and manages to defeat and kill frida
along with the rest of her family he had
some experience with titan abilities
that was the reason why he managed to
kill and eat frieders a titan that
almost matched his size and possessed
the founding titan number 13. ymir many
years ago a nameless ldn girl lived in
the streets of marley as a beggar with
no home eventually she was found by a
man who gave her the name ymir after the
ancestor yamir fritz and brought her
into a group dedicated to the worship of
ymir she was acclaimed by many aldians
in the group and yamir chose to abide by
her new role in order to bring happiness
to those around her despite knowing that
she did not descend from royalty
eventually the group was discovered by
the public security authorities to save
himself the man who found and named ymir
claimed that she had deceived him after
being paraded around marley and stoned
by angry citizens the members were taken
to the borderline of parody island and
forcibly turned into pure titans yamir
spent about 60 years wandering outside
walmaria as a pure titan until one day
she encountered young warriors she
attacked them and managed to eat marcel
galliard who had the power of the jaw
titan at the time she later joined the
104th training corps in order to find a
girl named krista lentz a while later
when they were surrounded by pure titans
at ugard castle after seeing no way out
yamir jumps from the tower and cuts
herself with the knife to trigger her
transformation this is the first time we
saw a jaw titan in the show despite her
small size yamir's titan form had above
average speed and agility which made it
easy for her to climb walls and trees
she dispatched multiple enemies in quick
succession by biting them in their nape
while using her claws and pointed teeth
however her size has proven to be a
problem since she was easily overpowered
by titans not long after her
transformation at utgarde castle ymir
also possessed the ability to partially
emerge from the nape of her titan form
allowing her to interact with others
while still being transformed she was
also one of the few titan shifters that
could talk in their titan forms if you
thought yamir was strong wait until you
see titans on the top of the list number
12 aaron krueger aaron krueger was an
alden spy posing as a marlene officer he
founded the ld and restorationists and
used the pseudonym the owl to
communicate secretly he possessed the
power of the attack titan kruger was
born to an eldian family living in
marley and his father was a member of
the eldian revolutionary army
unfortunately the army was very
ineffective and its members including
kruger's father were captured and burned
alive by the marlin officers as kruger
hid in a closet afterward he was rescued
by friends of his father some time later
krueger was able to join the public
security authorities as a spot thanks to
an elden doctor who was able to fake his
blood tests as a spy in the military
kruger would spend his military career
turning thousands of aldians into titans
over the years in order to hide his
identity 13 years after inheriting his
power kruger saves grisha from being
thrown off the wall while mutilating his
hand he taught grecia how to use the
power of the titans before in his titan
form destroying the marlin steamboat and
slaughtering all the remaining soldiers
as part of the attack titan's unique
abilities kruger was able to receive
memories of the future attack titan
holders he also showed incredible
strength as he could lift and destroy
the marlin ship number 11. porco
galliard porco galliard was a warrior
candidate who inherited the power of jaw
titan after the previous owner of the
titan yamir agreed to be taken to marley
and eaton four years after the warriors
return galliard is present at the battle
of fort slava under orders from the
marlin superiors led by commander mcgath
he engaged in battle as soon as the
gabby destroyed anti-titan artillery
after clearing their defenses galliard
keeps advancing towards the enemy
killing several soldiers inside the
trenches and using his powerful jaw to
break the railways porco had shown an
outstanding level of speed and agility
even for a titan he could cover great
distances while jumping both when he was
on the offensive and escaping from
incoming attacks he was so fast that he
was able to make surprise attacks that
the enemy was not able to predict he was
noted to be much faster than his
predecessor ymir galliard's most
prominent feature were his jaws which
were specifically made to bite very
durable material he had two sets of
teeth the first one is an exterior set
of hardened teeth and a second set is
located inside the mouth and it's a
series of pointy teeth with hollow
spaces between each individual tooth
this formidable weapon was efficient
enough to bite and crush the hardened
crystal of the warhammer titan number 10
falco grice if someone told you after
you started watching attack on titan
that there was going to be a flying
titan on the show you wouldn't believe
it would you well the amazing world of
attack on titan gave us one of the
craziest titans so far and his owner was
none other than falco falco grice is an
elden warrior candidate working for the
marley government he was originally one
of the main candidates to inherit the
armored titan power during the marlin
war with the mid-east allied forces
falco is present among other aldians
fighting on behalf of marley falco
survived the battle and returned to his
hometown liberio where he met aaron
jaeger who pretended to be a wounded
soldier named kruger falco was later
asked by aaron to deliver a letter for
him claiming that the letter is to
inform his family that he was safe and
sound inside the internment zone having
developed a sense of respect and
admiration for the man falco obliges
with the request a while later thanks to
the letter falco sent aaron managed to
contact his comrades in parody island
and organize an attack on marley after
aaron and survey corps successfully
defeated marley forces they were
retrieved by one of the airships gabby
and falco managed to hook onto an
airship and get on board after gabby
shot and killed sasha they were captured
and later imprisoned a while later after
escaping prison falco reunites with his
brother and learns that he accidentally
drank some of zeke's spinal fluid
although zeke expresses remorse for
falco's situation the news does not stop
him from screaming after he transforms
into a titan falco is immediately
ordered by zeke to kill reiner falco's
pure titan quickly gets the upper hand
and begins to bite through the armor
covering reiner's nape before he can
finish falco notices a severely injured
galliard nearby stumbling out of his
titan and devours him instead becoming
the new inheritor of the jaw titan he
would later transform for the first time
at parody harbor as he tries to help
reiner and annie like some of his
predecessors one of falco's most
prominent features as the jaw titan is a
hardened jaw specifically designed to
bite through durable materials like his
immediate predecessor falco's jaw titan
has two sets of jaws the interior is a
normal mouth and teeth while the
exterior is hardened and fashioned into
a beak due to having been transformed
into a pure titan by zeke yeager's beast
titan falco's jaw titan takes on some
animalistic traits found in birds and
later develops avian abilities and is
the first titan that could fly
number 9 reiner braun reiner braun is
the vice captain of the warrior unit and
the main protagonist of attack on titan
from the marlian perspective he is the
illegitimate son of an elden and a
marlian and grew up in the burials
internment zone eventually he was
selected as a child to become one of
marley's warriors at the age of 10 he
inherited the power of the armored titan
he infiltrated parody island alongside
bertolt annie and marcel as part of an
operation to reclaim the founding titan
in his armored titan form he destroyed
gates of walls letting a number of pure
titans in he later joined the survey
court after graduating second in the
104th training court after barely
surviving the battle with titans at
utgard castle brainerd crumbles under
the stress worrying that he will not
last much longer he sets aaron aside and
tells him that he is armor titan he gets
attacked by mikasa and engages in battle
with aaron in their titan forms while
transforming into the armored titan
brighner's body automatically produces a
hearted armor-like skin that covers most
of his body save for areas such as his
joints at the back of his legs the armor
is hard enough to repel concentrated
cannon fire without even stopping him
blows from other titans such as aaron as
well as blade strikes from the vertical
maneuvering equipment the durability of
this armor is enough to withstand a
direct collision from the colossus titan
who fell from the top of wall rose
incapacitating aaron's titan form and
leaving a large crater in the ground as
stated previously the armored titan can
choose to harden or not to harden joints
at will sacrificing speed and combat
ability for protection however similar
to medieval armor his body needs gaps
around the joints in order to move with
the necessary speed this makes him
vulnerable in just a few spots like the
inner part of his knees and his elbows
during the battle for shiganshina
district rhino was able to prevent his
certain death on multiple occasions
after transferring the functions of his
brain into the rest of his body with his
profound ability he was able to survive
a direct strike to his spinal cord in
the neck by levi's blade however it's
said that his ability is incredibly
difficult to successfully carry out and
is only used as a last resort this
proved to be the case when reiner
regained consciousness after
regenerating his head but lacked the
memories of everything that had happened
after party ways with berthold earlier
that morning besides its armor the
armored titan doesn't really have any
other notable abilities but since reiner
was a warrior specifically trained in
using his titan we think he deserves a
9th place on our list
number 8 lara tiber lara was an eldian
noble living in marley and secretly the
inheritor of the warhammer titan at some
point within the past 13 years she
inherited her titan powers though her
inheritance of these powers was kept a
closely guarded secret when the tiber
family arrives in liberio lara joins her
family to take up residence within the
headquarters lara observes willie's
production backstage during the night of
the festival where he shares the
knowledge of the great titan war
suddenly the production comes to a halt
when the attack titan bursts forth from
the building behind the stage killing
willy and starting a rampage lara
survives the destruction of the stage
and honors her brother for his work
starting her transformation into the
warhammer titan however the attack titan
turns to assault her before her
transformation can't complete
relentlessly beating her titan with
hardened fists she manages to stop the
barrage by using her powers to impale
the attack titan on a massive spike of
hardened titan flesh while she
regenerates her body upon fully
regenerating her titan lara generates
her titan's signature weapon to finish
off the attack titan without any desire
to consume the attack titan to gain the
stolen founder lara decapitates the
attack titan exposing aaron jaeger
within the nape the signature ability of
lara's titan was the power to
effortlessly generate massive spike-like
structures out of hardened titan flesh
ranging from ground spikes small enough
to go unnoticed or massive pikes large
enough to impale the 15 meter titan far
above the ground this structural
hardening also allowed for the warhammer
to create objects such as weapons
notably the signature warhammer for
which her titan is named much like the
female titan lyra could use this ability
to encase herself in a crystalline
barrier while encased in crystal lara
could create a body of a titan to be
remotely controlled from a distance
enabling her to regenerate her entire
titan body without sustaining any damage
to her human form as well as
circumventing the typical weakness of
the titan's nape number 7. eren yeager
attack titan aaron yeager was a former
member of the survey corps and the main
protagonist of attack on titan he lived
in shiganshina district with his parents
until the fall of walmaria where he
impotently witnessed his mother being
eaten by a titan this event would lead
to iron intense hatred towards the
titans as he swore to wipe off all of
them off the face of the earth after the
fall of the wall grisha found aaron and
took him to a nearby forest grisha
injected him with a titan serum turning
aaron into a mindless titan aaron
instinctively eats his father receiving
his attack titan powers including the
dormant founding titan during the battle
of trust aaron transforms into his
attack titan form for the very first
time and starts killing every titan he
comes across his titan form was
considerably more muscular and defined
making him much stronger than most of
the titans while his intelligence and
military training allowed him to
outmaneuver and dispatch entire groups
of titans with ease a transformation
took a heavy toll on aaron's body and
required large amounts of stamina as a
result he had displayed several symptoms
when he overexerted himself such as a
nosebleed pale skin and labored
breathing in some cases aaron was
rendered unconscious for a short period
of time after a titan transformation
initially aaron had no control over his
actions as a titan and was unable to
remember anything that occurred during
that time he was in a dreamlike state
and failed to remember how to transform
in the first place however aaron
recalled fragmented memories of his
father by seeing the key to the basement
of his old home and was able to
successfully transform to protect armin
and mikasa from certain death it had
been shown that with more
transformations aaron retained more of
his intelligence being able to form
rational thoughts after drinking a
bottle labeled armor from rod reese's
bag aaron's titan form gained the
ability to harden its body as well as
create a web of pillars that appear to
originate from his titan's body focusing
in his fists gave aaron a hardened punch
capable of easily breaking the armor
titan's face armor as part of the attack
titan's unique ability aaron could
reveal his own memories to his
predecessors giving them insight into
the future he gave memories of the
future to his father grisha selecting
the ones that would suit his purpose
number six annie leonhardt as a warrior
candidate annie was praised as
impeccable for her fighting abilities
and was later chosen as one of the seven
candidates to inherit the power of the
titans she was later granted the power
of the female titan in accordance with
her stellar combat skills and he was
selected as one of the four warriors to
carry out the parody island mission and
retrieve the founding titan a while
later she was present in her titan form
as the 57th expedition outside the walls
began as the female titan annie is
easily able to overpower veteran survey
corps members and wipe out several
squads in irwin's specialized scouting
formations she was far more experienced
in using her titan form compared to
aaron and was able to easily defeat him
she is arguably the most skilled titan
shifter we see in the series in terms of
hand-to-hand combat and he has high
mobility and endurance unlike most
human-controlled titans who are slower
than her and who tire out to the point
of collapsing during the 57th expedition
she was able to run long distances while
fighting against many soldiers and the
attack titan also after escaping the
survey corps trap she was able to
transform for a second time without an
extended recovery period and he is
capable of healing any injuries and even
regenerating any parts of her body that
were possibly lost in a battle however
she takes this ability to a new level
being able to focus this ability on
certain parts of her body healing the
chosen injuries at a much faster pace as
opposed to the automatic simultaneous
regeneration of all the damaged parts
she also possesses crystallization
abilities and he used this ability to
generate a cocoon of incredibly durable
crystal to trap herself in to avoid
being interrogated something that is
similar to the structural hardening
ability of the warhammer titan number 5
zeke jaeger z gigger has by far one of
the most unique stories in the whole of
attack on titan from betraying his
parents to betraying his whole nation
just for his cause as warrior candidate
he became very close with his superior
mr xavier who was the owner of the beast
titan together they thought of
euthanasia plan to free the world from
its fear of the titans and the albions
from their suffering by using the
founding titan's abilities to sterilize
all subjects of ymir thus leading to
their eventual extinction within 100
years he inherited the beast titan from
xavier and became military chief because
of his royal blood he had abilities that
none of the previous beast titan users
had he possessed immense physical
strength enough to break off large
chunks from wall rose and hurl them at a
great distance away his throwing ability
was second to none and he created a
visible sonic boom when he threw rocks
effectively throwing them faster than
over 700 feet per second zeke's unique
ability was a scream that can transform
the subjects of ymir into titans these
titans unlike the regular titans
encountered were capable of functioning
at night as long as the moon is out in
order for the human to turn into a titan
all the human must do is to intake
zeke's spinal fluid and then zeke can
use his scream to transform them these
titans are connected to his beast titan
via pats and obey his orders zeke was
able to harden his titan body at will to
protect himself from attacks however
this ability needed some time to prepare
during his brief battle with levi zeke
tried to harden the nape of his neck but
was unable to due to levi's increased
speed and attack not giving zeke enough
time to harden himself while offering
ample protection it can be damaged and
destroyed with the use of thunder spears
number four berthold hoover bertolt's
colossal titan is the most iconic titan
in the show his appearance in the very
first episode started a chain of events
that led us to the very end of attack on
titan although it stated multiple times
that zeke gaeger is the strongest marley
warrior we just can't see him defeating
bertolt's colossal titan form and that's
why we rank berthold higher on the list
bertolt hoover was an aldian born in
marley he was chosen to inherit colossal
titan after performing very well during
the warrior training his destructive
power was massive even at a young age he
was one of the four warriors sent to
parody island when they reached the
walls he transformed and destroyed the
gates of walmaria the colossus titan was
physically the strongest titan shown in
the series due to its immense size a
sweeping motion with one of his arms was
enough to destroy all the cannons on top
of wall rose as well as damage the upper
portion of the wall he was able to stop
aaron's titan form by simply jumping off
a wall and not even in his complete form
although all titans generate enormous
amounts of heat and energy when
transforming bertolt took this to the
next level he could control the energy
produced during his transformation to
create various effects for instance when
he attacked trust his transformation
only caused a wind blast that knocked
some trainees over the wall however
during the retake of shiganchina bertolt
releases a similar amount of energy to a
small nuclear device creating a mushroom
cloud of dust and rubble since bertolt's
titan form was far too slow to catch
more agile opponents he possessed a
powerful defense mechanism that involved
him releasing large amounts of extremely
hot and pressurized steam from his body
the steam had enough force to deflect
any cables shot from the vertical
equipment and burn away or repel close
range fighters it was shown that bertolt
could sustain the effort of producing
large quantities of steam for a limited
duration as seen in the fight on the top
of wall rose number three armin arlord
well there's another colossal titan on
our list and we are sure you'll agree
with us that this one is definitely
stronger than its predecessor armin is
one of the survey corps most valuable
assets even though he finished finishes
training outside the top 10 candidates
being physically weak armin is rarely
assigned to the front lines and rarely
uses his vertical equipment for direct
combat instead his greatest strength
lies in his intelligent innate abilities
of deduction and strategy formulation be
it in the war room or on the fly armin
has a keen eye for detail making him a
remarkable field tactician a trait that
distinguishes him among his fellow
trainees his strategies helped save his
fellow soldiers numerous times and more
remarkably he played a key role in
deducing the identities of all the
hostile titan spies among the 104th
training initially armin's intelligence
was hampered by a severe lack of
confidence but after acknowledging and
nurturing this side of himself armin's
potential as a tactician began to show
and even high-ranking officers took his
opinion seriously armin gained the power
of the titans specifically the colossal
titan after being injected with the
titan serum by levi and then consuming
bertold shortly afterward throughout the
show we only get to see armin using his
titan form a couple of times armin's
colossus titan possesses immense size
and strength capable of crushing entire
battleships underfoot armin can unleash
a massive explosion when transforming
into his titan he used this to great
effect during the raid on liberio
devastating the marlin navy with his
transformation and sending massive shock
waves inland in our opinion armand
deserves to be ranked higher than
birdhole simply because of his intellect
and tactical mind number two yamir fritz
yamir fritz was the progenitor of the
aldians when she was a young girl she
awakened the power of the titans and
became the first titan the founding
titan according to kruger this was done
when she came into contact with the
source of all living matter as a young
girl with this power ymir became the
progenitor of all titans the power of
her titan was the coordinating point
flinking unseen paths which united the
minds of her people the subjects of ymir
what she accomplished with her powers is
unknown but after 13 years the amir met
her death and her powers were split
between nine successors who went on to
build the eldian empire afterward all
inheritors of her power would be doomed
to die after 13 years as she did in a
phenomenon that would later be known as
the curse of ymir no titan would ever
possess more power than ymir had
possessed in her life ymir's existence
was hailed as a god-given miracle many
would claim that as the founding titan
she used her titan power to cultivate
barren lands build roads across the
nation and raise bridges through the
mountains of the world on the other hand
after the fall of the eldian empire in
the great titan war the new marley
government would spread slanderous
legends that yamir's power was derived
from the devil of all earth you're
probably wondering how can anyone be
stronger than yamir herself well let's
get to the top of our list and find out
number one aaron yeager founding titan
aaron's founding titan is the strongest
titan in the entire attack on titan
universe after realizing that he can use
the founding titan by coming into
contact with zeke aaron decides to
pretend to go along with his
half-brother's plan to sterilize the
subject of the emir after they make
contact and enter the paths aaron
discovers that the founder's power is
used by commanding a mere fritz and
learns that zeke not only nullified the
vow of renouncing war but that he
controls the power of the founder
showing that if a person with royal
blood possesses one of the nine titans
they can use the coordinates full power
instead of the actual holder aaron
eventually convinces ymir to lend him
her strength and uses the founding
titans to unleash all of the wall titans
while creating a body for himself that
is even larger than the colossus titan
he then uses the founder's power to
telepathically communicate with all of
the subjects of ymir informing them of
his plans to destroy the world outside
parody island the founding titan granted
its user the ability to control titans
at will and make them follow virtually
any order without question this was
demonstrated by aaron who
unintentionally commanded nearby pure
titans to eat dina fritz's titan and
attack the armored titan the founding
titan could transform the subjects of
emir into titans and could even make
them as massive as the colossus titan
carl fritz used this ability to create
the thousands of colossus titans that
made up the walls aaron used this
ability on an even greater magnitude
when he swiftly manifested numerous past
incarnations of the nine titans and
controlled them to attack his foes
simultaneously in the end aaron was
defeated by the combined efforts of the
survey corps and the warriors but as we
later learned aaron actually wanted them
to stop him and he didn't use his powers
to their full potential this means that
if he wanted to he could destroy the
entire world and defeat any other titan
shifter who dare oppose him with that
said he definitely deserves the top spot
on our list if you think we made any
mistake while ranking all of these
characters feel free to tell us in the
comments also click on this video to see
aaron's top 10 moments in attack on
titan